[Musik]
bis bald gast ist brought you the munich
haben sie herzlichen dank für diese sehr
genau weise einführung und auch die
einladung hierher und ich danke ganz
besonders thomas soll für die exzellente
organisation eine kleine korrektur ich
wurde in oxford von stephen williams
aber nicht von peter hecker betreut
sondern von dem monty williams also
genau die andere ecke aber auch von
gordon baker ich freue mich ganz
besonders in münchen zu sein weil ich
hier auch mein abitur gemacht habe ich
war hier auf dem asmus klasse gymnasium
in münchen für viele jahre also münchen
ist für mich auch zum teil eine münchen
ist zum teil auch an meine meine zweite
heimat und tragen sie mich jetzt besser
ok hören sie mich jetzt besser da musste
ich so sprechen würde ich war jetzt
einfach an und sprechen möglichst laut
aber ich werde nicht schreien geometrie
tors mit daisy tor
die übersetzt keiner soll eintreten der
der geometrie unkundig ist bekanntlich
soll dieser spruch über den eingang von
platons akademie gestanden haben
ob das stimmt oder nicht wissen wir
nicht genau doch der spruch ist durchaus
sehen sie eine platte uns zu verstehen
heißt es doch in der polit er die bürger
im idealen platonischen start dürften
auf keine weise der geometrie abhold
sein denn zum einen ist die geometrie
und auch die arithmetik die erkenntnis
des unveränderlichen science hat also
einer neurologischen wert zum anderen
nötigt ihr studium die menschliche seele
sich nach jener region hin zu wenden wo
die städte allen seins sie sich befindet
wo schließlich wodurch schließlich das
reine denken erleichtert wird nach
plattform hat die mathematik also eine
wichtige orientierungsfunktion für die
philosophie dennoch bleibt so platon das
studium der mathematik nur eine vorstufe
der waren philosophie im berühmten
linien gleichnis im sechsten buch der
polit er steht über der mathematischen
erkenntnis art ja noch die dialektische
erkenntnisse asis war sie beide verkennt
nicht sehen doch glatt und kritisiert
die mathematiker darf gehört dass ihr
beweise mit ungeklärten begriffen wie
gerade und ungerade et cetera operieren
so vermögen die mathematiker letztlich
nicht zu einer vernünftigen einsicht in
ihre gegenstände zu gelangen
zu dieser vernünftigen einsicht kommt es
erst durch die philosophische reflexion
der dialektik durch die die höchsten
prinzipien des wissens auch das
mathematischen aufgeklärt werden
beratung werde es daher niemals einen
gefallen von einem mathematischen
philosophie zu sprechen und die
philosophie als einen zweig der
mathematik zu konzipieren
doch die versuchung in der mathematik
eine oder gar die methode zur lösung
philosophischer probleme zu suchen ist
zu einem wichtigen motive der modernen
ära geworden erst recht in der
analytischen philosophie so schrieb
bertolt russell 1919 eine introduction
to mathematik philosophie
darin sprach er die hoffnung aus die
mathematische logik und möge helfen die
traditionellen probleme der philosophie
zu lösen und viele teilen diese hoffnung
bis heute dann versuchte ich verlor so
viel zu mathematisierung kann man zuerst
wohl bei reibungslos 13 jahrhundert
ausmachen
dieser suchte durch eine sogenannte
kombinations kunst eine art kombinatorik
oder us-general ist die verschiedenen
komplexen prädikate gottes aus einem
rohr prinzip systematisch abzuleiten
wobei das urprinzip in der mitte durch
neun einfache prädikat artikuliert wird
zum beispiel güter größte macht et
cetera bonita stahel
jeder dieser prädikate wird jeweils ein
buchstabe bbk zugewiesen nicht einfache
kombinations regeln können diese
buchstaben mechanisch vermieters von
scheiben jeweils zu zweit verbunden
werden und ergeben ein urteil das
bedeutet etwa das urteil bc das urteil
güter ist groß aber natürlich gottes
güte ist groß eis steht zu gott
auf diese weise sollten schließlich das
gesamte menschliche wissen dargestellt
werden gott erfasst werden und
schließlich auch die unglaublichen
ungläubigen bekämpft werden
natürlich sind diese ansprüche alle sehr
weit hergeholt es handelt sich hier nur
um einen mechanismus zur formung von
sätzen aus einem grund alphabet und
einer festgelegten syntaktischen vorn
dennoch viele wir bei lulu schon einige
aspekte des mathematischen paradigmas in
der philosophie angedeutet erstens kommt
hier das ideal einer symbolischen
kunstsprache auf mit deren hilfe die
urteile formen und übersichtlich
darstellen
zweitens setzt die behauptung dass diese
kunstsprache alle urteile menschlichen
wissens ausdrucken kann voraus dass alle
urteile auf eine ähnliche zahl von
grundkomponenten euro prädikaten
zurückgeführt werden kann
dies ist das ideal der zerlegen analyse
der komposition ahlen analysen letzte
semantische logische atome drittens wird
hier die kalkulierbarkeit der wahrheit
dieser urteile zumindest suggeriert null
los war noch nicht so weit er hat noch
kein kalkül aufgebaut dabei so scheint
es sollen noch neue wahrheiten auf diese
weise gefunden werden können
das ideal ist hier daher viertens eine
synthetische erfindung kunst eine art
inszenieren die und fünftens da im
prinzip dieser kombinations und
erfindung kunst alle urteile
menschlichen wissens erfasst werden alle
gegenstands bereiche und somit alle
wissenschaften unter einem nenner
gebracht eine einheits wissenschaft der
sechste mal das gewiss als ideal kommt
gleich auch vorbei bekam die
verheißungen der luft im kombinations
kunst wurden in der folgezeit nicht
vergessen und spätestens im siebzehnten
jahrhundert gewann sie wieder an
aktualität in einer zeit in der
fortschritt in der mathematik die
philosophie philosophische fantasie
ohnehin zu befeuern anfingen auf
descartes machte die deutsche
kombinations kunst scheinbar keinen
eindruck da er sie für eine rein
amerikanische darstellungsweise hielt
die bloß befähigt ohne urteil ich
zitiere hier von dingen zu sprechen von
denen man kein wissen hat ich habe aus
dem die kunden methode da abhandlung
über die methode schon 16 37 zitiert
diese logistik meinte der karte auch
matt ebenfalls also die formal logische
reduktion rente er aus demselben grund
aber logik erlaubt die uns nicht zu
denken ja und er lernte man höre und
staune auch ab die analyse der alten die
mathematische analyse alten um die
algebra oder nein aber das ist reine
rhetorik wenn tatsächlich score sollte
descartes sehr wohl eine neue
wissenschaftliche methode aufbauen
die genau juristisch vorteile der logik
geometrie und algebra nutzt damit meinte
er eine matthesius und dieser sei ließ
der card kennen sie alle
eine materie ist universal ist eine
wissenschaft die sowohl die mathematik
als auch die astronomie musik mechanik
optik unter sich fast also alle
teilgebiete die ordnung und mars
untersuchen als beispiel der
vereinheitlichung zweier dieser
teilgebiete der algebra geometrie
präsentierte karte im anhang zu seinem
disco denn traktat von geometrie mit
einer bekanntlich die analytische
geometrie begründete so verstanden ist
die matthesius universal es nur eine
lokale einheits wissenschaft nämlich die
der quantifizierbaren größen und nicht
die einheits wissenschaft war neben und
nicht immer genau unterschieden
unterschieden viel wir aber bei der kart
die umfassende revision einer absoluten
universal wissenschaft oder einen
absoluten universalen einheits
wissenschaft zu der auch die philosophie
gehört und die sich in mehreren
hinsichten am vorbild der mathematik
orientiert die vermischung der
spezielleren matthesius universal es mit
dieser absoluten universalen einheits
wissenschaft findet sich auch bereits an
der zitierten stelle im disco dort gibt
der card folgende methodische regeln an
erstens ein wahrheit' kriterium zweitens
eine analytische regel
und drittens eine synthetische regeln
das war heitz kriterium besagt ich
zitiere niemals eine sache als war
anzunehmen
die ich nicht als solche sicher und
einleuchtend erkennen kann die ich also
bezweifeln könnte nach der analytischen
regel zweitens soll ich jedes problem in
so viele teile zerlegen können wie
möglich und notwendig tatsächlich muss
sich aber weiter scheitern zu einer
analytischen zerlegung in einfachste und
der biss cremig deutlichste objekte weil
die bei drittens die synthetische regel
voraussetzt von diesen einfachsten und
deutlich sondern wirkt dann zurück zur
erkenntnis der kompliziertesten
erkenntnisse stufenweise aufzusteigen
hier kann man natürlich noch die regeln
3 und 5 auge aus den regula aus dem
regeln dem buch regeln ergänzen wurde
card alle genuine erkenntnis als
intuition und reduktion charakterisiert
intuition ist dabei müheloses
entwicklung ist dabei müheloses und
deutliches bestimmtes begreifen alle
einfachsten tatsachen aus dem licht der
vernunft und der reduktion einfach eine
kette von intuition dieses analytische
synthetische verfahren fängt demnach mit
verwickelten dunklen positionen an
reduziert sie vermittelt intuition auf
das alle einfachste und beweist daraus
alle weiteren wahrheiten wie
verschiedene forscher zum beispiel
hintergrund und rihms junge mittelstraße
hans jürgen engesser gezeigt haben
geht dieses verfahren dieses
analytisches sympathische verfahren auf
eine bestimmte auffassung mathematische
vor allem geometrischer beweise in der
antike zurück etwa bei paphos im dritten
viertel jahrhundert descartes beispiel
in den regulär stand allerdings aus der
arithmetik und ist das beispiel
ich fange mit der verwickelten tatsache
so sozusagen verwickelten tatsache zwei
plus zwei ist gleich drei plus eins an
um diese zu beweisen muss sich die
einfachen tatsache zwei plus zwei ist
gleich vier und die einfache tatsache
drei plus eins ist gleich hier einsehen
und zudem einsehen dass durch
substitution von gleich die gleichung
sich gleich es ergibt also letztendlich
zwei plus zwei ist 444 ist auch dass die
drei plus 1 4 und 4s identisch also kann
ich habe ich meinen beweis dividend der
produktiven beweises hier ergibt sich
also durch die zurückführung auf selbst
evidente gleichungen als glieder einer
intuitiven ketten der karte benutzt dann
auch andere formen von dieses
analytischen synthetischen verfahrens
rag basiert zum beispiel dass ich das
zweite beispiel hier auch auf dem herrn
dort aber das werde ich jetzt dann nicht
mehr ausführen
ob der card recht vage methodische
regeln genügen auch nur mathematische
beweise zu erklären oder eine effektive
methode zur entdeckung neuer
mathematischer wahrheiten zu finden ist
sehr fraglich
jedenfalls war der cut von solche
mathematischen beweisen so sehr
beeindruckt dass er sie zum paradigma
allen wissenschaftlichen wissens er hob
seine mathematische inspirationsquellen
trebbin also über den engen raum einer
speziellen matthesius universalist
hinaus die ich davor warnt habe ihm dies
chur zum beispiel schreibt er dass in
dieser berühmte stelle dass die langen
beweiskette der geometer in suggerieren
würden ich zitiere alle dinge die
menschliche erkenntnis zugänglich sein
könnten einander auf dieselbe weise
folgen wie nach dem motto
wie sie hier sozusagen die nach diesem
modell und ihnen dann regulär ist der
karte noch deutlicher ich zitiere wer
den weg der wahrheit sucht darf mit
einem gegenstand umgehen über den er
nicht eine den arithmetischen oder
geometrischen beweisen gleiche
gewissheit gewinnen kann
das erklärt warum descartes machen der
quartz mathematische position sie ein
dreieck ist von von nur drei seiten
begrenzt dort eine kugel nicht nur von
einer fläche begrenzt im selben atemzug
erwähnt wie philosophisch relevante
aussagen wie ich denke ich existiere etc
wie findet hier eine weitere komponente
des mathematischen paradigmas in der
philosophie nämlich nämlich die
forderung in der philosophie die gleiche
art von gewissheit wie in der mathematik
anzustreben um solche tat entgegen
seinen eigenen versicherungen und
entgegen seinem aktuellen exegeten
stephen doc docx oder gar nicht so weit
von niveaus entfernt
auch der grad hält an einer zerlegen
analyse fest und glaubt an die
möglichkeit einer findungskommission
einer einheits wissenschaft wenn was ihm
an lulus kombinations kunst nicht gefiel
war ja dass fehlern evidenter urteile
sobald die wir die haben können wir
tatsächlich senat universale
kombinations kunst formulieren und so
scheut der dass die erfindung einer
nation symbol sprache in der man alle
dinge ausdrücken kann
die menschlichen geist vorkommen können
von der wahren philosophie abhängt damit
meinte der card dass diese sprache erst
gebildet werden kann wenn ihr elementar
das vokabular fest steht dass nämlich
die jenes vokabular dass die einfachsten
ideen benennt und das setzt natürlich
eine analyse des bewusstseins voraus
diese einfachsten ideen soll durch die
auffindung der einfachsten
metaphysischen positionen gewonnen
werden das heißt den positionen ich
existiere
meditation ich existiere ich bin ein
denkendes ding und gott existiert das
sind die drei fundamentalen
kernpositionen der meditationen und
tatsächlich bezeichnete card die methode
seines buches ausdrücklich als
analytisch wenn wir also erst einmal die
elementaren mit der physischen
wahrheiten ausmachen können könnten wie
abstrakte symbole für sie einführen und
schließlich nach der von descartes
anvisierten art der mathematiker rechnen
doch der gsma thematisierung der
philosophie blieb nur ein utopisches
projekt er selbst verwies die
realisierbarkeit einer solchen sprache
in das land der märchen
wir können hier kritisch ohnehin nach
sagen welches ist das kriterium der
einfachheit einer mathematik ein solch
einer metaphysischen wahrheit durch
solche methode der analytischen
zerlegung gewinnen wir sie genau gibt es
in der philosophie die erkenntnis quelle
der intuition und sind philosophische
schlussfolgerungen aneinanderreihungen
von intuitiven wahrheiten
inwiefern ist die methode der
meditationen das heißt der fortschritt
von der hilfs annahme dass ich
eigentlich gar nichts wissen in der
ersten meditation zur gewissheit dass
ich existiere in der zweiten meditation
und sofort wirklich vergleichbar mit
einer wänden beispielen mathematische
analysen und beweisen bei jenen
mathematischen besten beispielen
handelte sich um beweise durch
zurückführen auf gleichungen durch
algebraische umformungen aber
zurückstellung dann auf gleichung und
durch solche umformungen sie in der
philosophie eigentlich nicht zu haben
jedenfalls sind die metaphysischen
kernpositionen der meditationen wie das
gesicht dieser und so weiter nicht so
gewonnen
solche probleme wurden im 17 jahrhundert
nicht viel thematisiert obwohl der karte
natürlich der sehr prominent ran
das mathematische ideal faszinierte
denker wie hobbs pascal male branche
spinoza athanasius kircher erhard weigel
und natürlich leibniz wgl
jänner leben lehrer von leibnitz schrieb
schon 1693 eine abhandlung mit dem titel
und die mathematischen philosophen denen
wir das interessant finden von der
vortrefflichkeit der mathematischen
philosophie gegenüber des callers
tischen katalanischen philosophie weigel
suchte die aristotelische mit der physik
nach der exotischen methode von euch
kriegs geometrie darzustellen
also mit hilfe von definitionen
postulate nationen und terror rahmen
dieses romantische methode nach
geometrische art er freute sich einiger
beliebtheit so etwas auch schon wichtig
er sollte sich einige beliebtheit wie
man das zum beispiel an spielen uns dass
ethik am besten sehen kann
allerdings kommentierte schon der
philosoph mathematiker pierre le beau
partie dieser methode kritisch in dem er
schrieb man sollte sich nicht von
philosophischen werken täuschen lassen
die vorgeben mathematisch zu sein bloß
weil ein philosoph die ausdrücke lema
theorem schlusssatz aufsagen kann
bedeutet das nicht dass ein werk die
gewissheit der mathematik regie zitat
ende
leibnitz bemängelt denn die wahrheit die
wahrheit der katalanischen
mathematischen methoden regeln und
wollte es besser machen
von anfang an galt sein augenmerk der
schaffen einer kunstsprache einer
charakteristika universales und eines
kalkül des kalküls radio senator er
wollte er lulus kombinations kunst
realisieren der wollte wirklich dieses
programm umsetzen
von dieser kombinations kunst oder sie
leiden ist sie nannte kunst der
unfehlbarkeit oder universalen
mathematik versprach sich leiden enorm
viel schon seine dieser partie derart
kombinatorik von 1666 die er übrigens
als 20 jährige schrieb sollte eine neue
philosophische rechnungs art der
universalen wahrheit form kreieren mit
deren hilfe
sollten andere völker von den wahrheiten
der natürlichen religion überzeugt
werden
auch die philosophie sollte davon
profitieren denn wenn wir über eine
universelle sprache verfügen die tiere
ich hier könnten wir in der metaphysik
und amoral so resümieren sie in der
geometrie und der analysis und ich
zitiere weiter wenn eine
meinungsverschiedenheit zwischen zwei
philosophen aufkommen würde so wäre sie
genauso einfach zu schlichten wie ein
streit zwischen zwei buchhaltern denn es
würde genügen den stift in die hand zu
nehmen
sie hatte sich an den schreibtisch zu
setzen und sich zu sagen kalkuliert
lasst uns rechnen
worauf gründet daher leiden nichts
solche hoffnungen auf dem board
theoretischen theologischen
metaphysischen erkenntnistheoretischen
und letztlich natürlich auch logischen
gründen
ihnen allen jedoch liegt die mathematik
als strukturprinzip zugrunde ich will
dass ganz kurz skizzieren bleiben wollte
dass seine liga charakteristika das
wesen der dinge erfassen soll
sie soll er nicht das sprechen sondern
die gedanken abbilden sowie die sowie
die algebra und weiter ich zitiere die
zeichen die nada am besten der kunst des
erfindens wenn sie das innere wesen des
ding das ausdrücken und gleichsam malen
so sind die zeichen in meinem kalkül sie
führen sie ins innere der dinge selbst
bleiben die zins charakteristik basiert
also auf einer behaupteten und er hoffte
die sanofi zwischen unserer sprache
unseren gedanken und der struktur der
wirklichkeit eine kritische frage stellt
sich sofort ist schon das zeichensystem
der algebra überhaupt eine sprache
das heißt drückte es gedanken aus nur
dann kann man von einer summe zwischen
gedanken zu wollen und der welt reden
die als etwa das modell für die formale
sprache der philosophie dienen
kann nehmen wir zum beispiel das links
diskutierte gesetz der algebra das hier
angezeigt ist
sie scheinen wir letztendlich bloß eine
umformung regel von schematischen
buchstaben zu haben ohne dass ein wahrer
gedanke und damit ausgedrückt wird
deswegen heißt ja auch die algebra hieß
früher buchstaben rechnung
damit würde aber wenn was ich sage ich
hier korrekt ist eine aus der
algebraischen symbolik inspiriert
desomorphin zwischen sprache gedanken
und wirklichkeit für eine
mathematisierung der philosophie schon
im ansatz suspekt sein
leibnitz schrieb wenn gott rechnet und
sein denken in die tat umsetzt entsteht
die welt ein sehr schöner gedanke finde
ich mit anderen worten die welt ist die
schöpfung eines die schöpfung eines
rechnen gottes und ist mathematisch
geordnet denken urteilen und schließen
sie dass sie berechnen wie begriffen und
daher lässt sich die wahrheit eines
urteils letztendlich berechnen
dabei ist jede wahrheit für leighton
jetzt immer auf eine identität
zurückzuführen durch fortgesetzte
substitution ein einfaches beispiel in
der analytischen urteil menschen sind
lebewesen steckte der begriff mensch der
aus den begriffen vernünftige und
lebewesen besteht also formalisieren wir
nach leibnitz instituts kalkül begriff
sei international gedeutet
folgendermaßen hier haben sie denn den
beweis dass sozusagen menschen lebewesen
ich weiß nicht ob ich das jetzt nicht
mehr das soll nur ein beispiel sein wie
ihr hier vorgeht ist eine reine all
gebracht
schon begriff von begriffen die aussage
menschen sind lebewesen ist wenn dieser
beweis korrekt ist diese nämlich durch
die begriff zerlegung des begriffes
menschen vernünftig
gewesen der dritte punkt sozusagen ist
er der entscheidende ich beim restart
und dann natürlich die schon vorn und
zur rückführung der begriffe auf eine
völlige identität eine gleichung eine
völlige identität ist eine an sich
selbst klare wahrheit so leibnitz und
sie haben dann eine vollkommen evidenz
erreicht wie in der mathematik
normalerweise diese unkomplizierte art
formulierte leiden die zunehmend neuen
anläufen sehr bemerkenswerte kalküle
doch nicht alle urteile sind so leicht
zu beweisen vor allem nicht die nicht
analytischen urteile etwas etwa sokrates
schläft jedem mittwochnachmittag
dennoch glaubt leibnitz dass auch
kontingente urteile sich im prinzip auf
identität und zurückführen lassen müssen
denn wahrheit besteht hier in der
patienten oder voll von identität
zwischen subjekt und prädikat dafür
müssten wir alle attribute von sokrates
kennen nämlich seinen sogenannten
individual begriff für gott ist das ein
klacks doch für uns menschen lassen sich
individuell begriff wenn nun in die
unendliche anhörung erreichen sozusagen
ihn findet er sie mal bleibe nichts
erklärt also den unterschied zwischen
analytischen und kontingenten wahrheiten
hinaus deutliche parallele zur
mathematik analytische wahrheiten
unterscheiden sich von kontingenten
sowie kommen zur ablöse von nicht kommen
sollen zahlen
auch allgemein begriffe lassen sich
nicht immer so einfach wie in diesem in
einem vorherigen beispiel mensch der
begriff mensch zu legen
wir brauchen also eine methode der real
definition mit der wir jeden gegebenen
begriff in seiner letzten bestandteile
zerlegen können und dieser letzten
bestandteile muss es nach leiden lizenz
erkenntnistheorie geben wenn allem
erkennen muss etwas zu grunde
das durch sie selbst erkannt ist und
dass daher einfach sein muss meint
leibnitz nun erkennen wir wenn auch
nicht durch sich selbst dass es sogar
des schläft also muss dieses kontingente
urteilen anfang an einfach der
bestandteile auf lösbar sein
also muss es einfach den begriffen nach
leibnitz geben haben wir diese
bestandteile dieser einfachsten begrüße
so besitzen wir die bausteine zur
kombination aller möglichen urteile die
wir dann mit dem kalkül beweisen oder
widerlegen können das ergebe die lange
cent in metaphysische erfindung kunst
spätestens hier bei der gewinnung der
einfachsten begriffe des grundkapitals
der charakteristik alisa salis gelangen
wir an die grenzen von leib lizenz
vision
ich möchte ich kurz ein paar probleme
nennen zum einen finden sich hier wie
beide card die idee in der philosophie
könne man durch reine oder quasi alle
bereiche umformungen substanziellen
wahrheiten gelangen
das setzt voraus dass wir unsere
begriffe genau definieren können sie in
der mathematik bleiben jetzt vermochte
aber nie ein kriterium dessen anzugeben
was ein allereinfachsten begriff sein
sollten wir gewinnen können
zudem widerspricht dem unendliche
analyse kontingente urteile nicht dann
nicht teile der existenz einfachste
begriffen
es sei denn wir wollen in analogie
zwischen der sie mal rechnung von
unendlich klein oder einfachen begriff
entsprechen aber ich glaube dass das
keinen sinn macht es ist auch etwas
seltsam dass ein so banales urteil sie
sokrates schläft aus unendlich vielen
begriffen bestehen soll
so wie es auch unverständlich ist was
ein beweis aus unendlich vielen
schritten überhaupt sein soll
bleiben diese mathematische paradigma
intel aktualisiert hier bestimmte
logische semantische dort sachen bis zu
unkenntlichkeit
und ich glaube das ist ein paralleles
problem auch in manchen heutige und
semantischen theorien gibt darauf komme
ich zurück bleiben die zwar lange zeit
davon überzeugt wir könnten die
einfachsten begriffe finden indem wir
ihnen jeder jeweils charakteristische
zahl und primzahlen zu ordnen könnten
wir dann mit ihnen rechnen
hier wird aber klar dass die bestimmung
des vokabulars der charakteristik schon
eine vorgängige analyse voraus setzt
nämlich eine vorgängige analyse die die
zu repräsentieren den elementaren
strukturen des denkens und der welt
identifiziert doch wie ist diese analyse
zu führen ohne symbol ein vielleicht das
vokabular der kunstsprache ich schreibe
a steht für den gedanken in meiner
muttersprache habe ich also schon ein
symbol für die für den gesuchten
gedanken nämlich b diese charakter
charakterisieren der sache doch woher
kommt dieses symbol wie setzen wir also
schon eine vorgängige nichts normal
analyse des normalisierten wirklich ist
voller aus wie machen sie das überhaupt
ohne schon zirkular vorzugehen und genau
dieses problem stellt adolf
trendelenburg 150 jahre nach leibnitz
fest übrigens in einem kleinen einer
sehr interessanten artikel der kurze
zeit später frage dazu motiviert mich
zusätzlich haben so eine kunstsprache zu
tun zu versuchen mitschüler folgen wir
wissen da bleiben schließlich keine
apriori methode der begriff zerlegung
ein spiel versucht er sich dadurch zu
helfen dass er die enzyklopädie an
seiner zeit studierte und daraus listen
von definitionen einfache begriffe
komplette wie ich finde ein
hoffnungsloses unterfangen und sowohl
der leibniz gegen ende seines lebens
immer skeptischer hinsichtlich der
mathematisierung der philosophie
doch andere versucht und seine vision
zumindest zum teil weiter zu führen
sein einflussreichster anzusagen gleich
steinherr anhänger christian soll es zb
in seinem diskurs limina dies von 1728
versuchte die methode der philosophie
ausdrücklich mit der methode der
mathematik gleichzusetzen denn was beide
disziplinen charakterisiert so holz ist
eine genaue definition ihrer ausdrücke
sowie wahrheit als strenge beweisbarkeit
ausgewiesen und unerschütterlichen
grundsätzen aus diesem grund weiter wolf
kann die philosophie des denselben grad
an gewissheit erreichen sie die
mathematik denn die mathematik ich
zitiere aus holz gibt uns ein muster der
vollkommensten manier 1 aus dem anderen
zu schließen so welche der menschliche
verstand gelangen kann wenn er den
höchsten gipfel der vollkommenheit
ersticken hat zitat ende
diese parallele zwischen mathematik und
philosophie hat allerdings den einspruch
manche zeitgenossen des bösen wolf
produziert zum beispiel seines
politischen gegners christian kruse ist
ein ganz wichtiger und leider vergessen
der philosoph der in seinem buch weg zur
gewissheit und zuverlässigkeit der
menschlichen vernunft von 1747 gleich
neun differenzen zwischen der
philosophie und der mathematik skizziert
allerdings nur auf zwei seiten also
nicht er hat sich nicht sehr sehr stark
damit auseinandergesetzt
zum beispiel ein argument von crusius
hieß das in der mathematik sie das in
der mathematik definition presse in
genau sind weil sie durch konstruktionen
ensi entstehungsort direkt gegeben
werden oder aber auch er sagt das nur in
der philosophie wie es mit einer
moralischen betrachtungsweise des
endzweck seiner sache zu tun haben aber
nicht in der mathematik und so weiter
von crusius inspiriert sie wissen wir
jetzt als nächstes kommt er habe auch
der junge kann einspruch gegen die
leitindizes
solche parallelen zwischen der
philosophie und der mathematik schon der
vor kritische kannte in der untersuchung
über die deutlichkeit im grundsätze der
natürlichen theologie der moral von 1764
ganz anders in der mathematik kann man
tatsächlich von definitionen ausgehen
weil dieses ihn tätig sind
das heißt die einen gegenstand gleichsam
erschaffen
der begriff das erklärt dann
entsprechend alle erst durch die
erklärung und hat weiter gar keine
bedeutung als die so ihm die definition
eine gibt zitat ende
weiter sagt ganz in der philosophie sind
dagegen die begriffe schon vor ihrer
erklärung dieser definition gegeben und
wir übersehen sehr leicht manche ihrer
merkmale wodurch wir häufig falsche
definitionen angeben in der mathematik
haben wir direkte erkenntnis mittel ihre
gegenstände nämlich ähnliche symbole die
zeichen der philosophischen erkenntnis
dagegen sind die großen worte unseres
rede gebrauchs deren bedeutung das heißt
die zugrunde liegen und begriffs
merkmale uns nicht immer sofort
ersichtlich sind
im obigen beispiel eines bleiben die
zwischen beweises wurde das wichtigste
natürlich schon am anfang so ausgesetzt
nämlich die begriff zerlegung von mensch
als vernünftig plus lebewesen um wie
viel schwerer ist eine solche begriffs
zerlegung im fall ist und philosophisch
wirklich relevanten begriffen wie zum
beispiel vorstellung raumzeit
erhabenheit schönheit regierte und so
weiter und so fort
außerdem argumentiert kant dass unsere
rede
oberflächlich zu gleichmacherei neigt
begann ziemlich ähnlich wittenstein
wir sagen zum beispiel der mensch
unterscheidet das wort vom messing
aber wir sagen auch die kuh
unterscheidet gras vom heute aber
unterscheiden bedeutet nicht das selbe
in beiden sätzen ich war im ersten fall
bedeutet unterscheiden denn unterschiede
erkennen welches niemals geschehen kann
urteilen den zweiten vor allem im fall
der kuh bedeutet unterscheiden einfach
bei unterschiedlichen vorstellungen
unterschiedlich halt und handeln und das
war es die vier urteilen nicht
die moral von ganz kritik ist was es
nutzen dass ja gefährlich sein kann
schematische quasi mathematische
buchstaben die philosophie einzuführen
ohne sich über den vielfältigen gebrauch
eines ausdrucks zuerst bewusst zu sein
jedenfalls warnte kant noch in der
kritik der reinen vernunft von den
eignern anmaßungen dass philosophen sich
mit den titeln und bändern der
mathematik austauschen auszuschmücken
wir kommen nun zum nächsten
protagonisten wissen wie spät ist es
okay danke
okay man könnte nun einwenden dass
leibnitz scheitern musste weil ihm ein
entscheidendes instrument fällte die
prädikaten logik er ist die prädikat an
logik erlaubt es uns die innere struktur
der urteile und gedanken zu erschließen
und die elementaren bausteine zu
identifizieren die prädikaten logik
erfahren wie du siehst und gottlob frege
1879 in seinem buch geschweige war
allerdings viel vorsicht die gästekarte
und leibnitz er wollte zunächst seine
begriff schrift zu der auch ein sehr
leistungsfähiger kalkül gehörte nicht
dass ein universales symbolsprache und
philosophischer findungs kunst
verstanden wissen sondern bloß ich
zitiere als eine lingua charaktere wie
er sagt nicht charakteristika charakter
rica
charaktere hat zunächst für die
mathematik
mit ihrer hilfe sollte und dann erst ins
arithmetische beweise aus strengste
weise das heißt ohne anschauung auf ihre
gültigkeit überprüft werden
zweitens arithmetische setzung gesetze
auf rein logischen selbst evidente
prinzipien in aktion mit zurückgeführt
werden das natürlich das programm der
not des lobbyismus arithmetik osteologie
und drittens die struktur die mettinger
setzte durch logische analyse zur legung
aufzudecken und uns zu zeigen von
welchen gegenständen sie wirklich
handeln also was zum beispiel zahlen
wirklich und theologisch gesehen sind
und viertens neu und fruchtbar begriffe
auch schon bekannten begriffen zu
erzielen dann vielleicht dann
entsprechend neue wahrheiten als
fernziel zu formulieren und zu beweisen
sind ja also durchaus einige das schon
eingetroffenen elemente des
mathematischen paradigmas kunstsprache
zerlegen der analyse kalkulierbarkeit
gewissheit ideal ja sogar eine art
erfindung kunden wenn auch zunächst nur
auf die mathematik beschränkt nur von
einem streben nach einer
mathematisierung thematisierten einheits
wissenschaft und er unter der auch die
philosophie zu subsumieren ist kann man
soll hier nicht sprechen
träge sagt es ja deutlich das verhältnis
zwischen der begriff schrift und der
sprache der liebe und des lebens wir die
natürliche sprache nennt ist das des
auges zum mikroskop nun sowie das
mikroskop ist auch die begriff schriften
bloß ein instrument so ganz bestimmte
zwecke nämlich sie den zweck den
begrifflichen und in friends ihren
inhalt von arithmetischen urteilen zu
artikulieren
daraus scheint zu folgern dass man die
begriff schrift nicht verwenden kann und
die sprache des lebens und die darin
artikulieren begriffe aus der die
philosophie letztendlich erwächst zu
erfassen
daher klingt es auch seltsam wenn
michael damit schreibt frege
hätte eine genauso überwältigende
philosophische resolution losgedreht
dann wieder kart und design genauso
großer denker wie aristoteles und kann
und doch ist die begriff schlicht kein
bloßes instrument strecke scheint ja zu
glauben dass eine langsame schrittweise
annäherung an leibnitz ins horn ziel
möglich ist
so könne man die begriff schrift auf die
formensprache der geometrie dynamik
mechanik chemie ausdehnen und diese
miteinander verbinden
da sie die begriff schlicht ein gebiet
erschließt das in der mieter dieser
wissenschaften liegt das hört sich also
doch nach einer vision der einheits
wissenschaft an
jedenfalls soll laut frage auch die
philosophie von der begriff schrift
profitieren ich zitiere selbst
unterstelle austräger wenn er seine
aufgabe der philosophie ist die
herrschaft des wortes über den
menschlichen geist zu brechen indem sie
die begriffe nicht enttäuschungen
aufdeckt die durch den sprachgebrauch
entstehen
so wird meine begriff schrift für diese
zwecke weiter ausgebildet den
philosophen ein brauchbares werkzeug
werden können sie dort ende aufregend
dann auch gleich ein beispiel für den
begrifflichen logischen fortschritt denn
seine begriff lichtblick bringen soll
die ersetzung von subjekt und prädikat
durch argument und funktion
damit sind wir beim kern von
registrierungen schafft seine analyse
von urteilen die explizit auf der imm
portierung eines mathematischen begriffs
basiert den begriff der funktion
sozusagen schräges motto die theorie der
funktionen war ein sehr wichtiges thema
mathematische forschung
grundlagenforschung gemacht und im 19
jahrhundert eine mathematische funktion
kann grob gesagt hast eine korrelation
zwischen zahlen angesehen werden
nach dem prinzip input output denn input
nennen wir das argument denn am output
den wert da das argument variieren kann
bezeichnen wir seine stelle mit einer
variablen ein wert ist immer der wert
einer funktion für ein bestimmtes
argument zu jedem argument kann es nur
genau einen wert geben habe nicht
umgekehrt mehrere argumente können zum
selben weg führen und soll zu selben
wert führen weil natürlich eine funktion
eine recht eindeutige relation ist ein
einfaches beispiel die jahre die die
mathematische funktion exakt 2 für die
argumente 1 2 oder 3 erhalten hier
jeweils die wörter 14 und 19
die funktion exakt 2 hat also für
bestimmte argumente einen bestimmten
wert verlauf und nur genau diesen wert
soll auf die korrelation zwischen
bestimmten argumenten und an und wird so
laut definiert geradezu die identität
der funktion oder die eine funktion
unterscheidet sie von anderen funktionen
wenn eine funktion für die argumente 1 2
und 3 nicht die werte 14 und 9 ergibt
sondern die werte 30 und 9
dann müssen wir eine andere funktion vor
uns haben nämlich diesem fall die
funktion zwei classics das umgekehrte
gilt nicht ein wert kann als der wert
verschiedener funktionen sie
verschiedene argumente analysiert werden
nehmen wir als beispiel die zahl neun
die zahl neun kann als wert der funktion
exakt 2 wie das argument 3 oder als
werther funktion sie beim sex für das
argument 2 angesehen werden art
infinitum traditionelle logik auch
leiden jetzt fast in einem urteil die
aller menschen sind lebewesen nachdem
grammatikalischen schema von subjekt und
prädikat auf
nun sind aber nicht alle urteile dieser
art schon gar nicht in der mathematik
ein einfaches beispiel es gibt keine
größte natürliche zahl hier haben wir ja
nicht einmal ein zu wirkt es ist ja kein
subjekt dies nur dass das ihn definitiv
oder zum beispiel einander ein anderes
beispiel sein exkurs y nächsten liebsten
und größer als 2 dennis ex größe frei
gemacht nun folgen dass er wenn er diese
urteile analysiert erpresst das zu
analysierende urteil nicht ihnen das
relativ rigiden subjekt prädikat schema
sondern er liest ihnen die viel
flexiblere argument er erließ die viel
flexiblere argument funktion struktur
ihnen das urteil kann also schon mit dem
fertigen urteil an
er tut dies in deiner singen oder
termini zumindest erste stufe durch
variablen ersetzt ein einfaches beispiel
fiel durch sein hund daraus viel die
funktion oder die felge aus sagt der
begriff sex ist ein hund 1 1 ein anderes
beispiel in relation zum beispiel vieler
verfolgt wie das sind alles hunde daraus
gewinnen wir die zwei ställe für
zweistellige funktion ex verfolgt wie
viel aber auch denn wir wollen wieder
verfolgt y oder ex erfolgt y unendlich
viele weil hier hoch kontaktieren können
diesen diesen anfang an urteilen und ist
einfach über die funktionen begriffe
sind unvollständig oder die pflege auch
sagt ungesättigt man sättigt sie indem
man sie mit einem argument für dort sido
und die argument stelle dann mit einem
quanto oder miteinander verbindet shrek
ist funktional analyse ergibt so für
alle menschen sind lebewesen zu alex
wenn ex ein mensch ist dann ist ex ein
lebewesen das heißt was als ein
einfaches subjekt und prädikat
ursprünglich aussah stellt sich nun als
ein komplexes bedienung bedingung
vorteil heraus dass eigentlich vier
funktionen hat
das werde ich jetzt nicht ausführen aber
das ist so darunter sogar eine funktion
zweiter stufe man man man höre und
staune
wir schreiben also mit hilfe der
funktionellen analyse eine tiefere
struktur des urteils gefunden zu haben
die der malta sprachlichen
grammatikalischen auge total entgeht
das regelt begriff schlicht zudem
zweidimensional ist können wir ihre
formeln beinahe wie big programme der
tieferen struktur von urteilen und der
kriegs und ansehen was natürlich auch
seine schönen ästhetischen reiz hat ich
musste dass dieses leid importieren aus
einer anderen vorlesung die habe ich mit
latex gemacht das kommt davon wenn man
besser wenn man kann ich solche formeln
schöne formeln skizzieren sind man muss
sie als image sozusagen importieren und
die funktionale analyse hat noch andere
allseits bekannte vorteile sie keine
urteile höhere stufe und beliebiger
komplexität erfassen ob sie mehrfach
einfach oder gar nicht quantifiziert
sehen vor allem aber zeigt reges
identifizierung von begriffen und
funktionen scheinbar etwas völlig neues
über das wesen der begriffe sie sind
ungesättigte dinge können wir nicht hier
tatsächlich dann von einer fundamentalen
philosophischen entdeckung sprechen
bewirkt durch die einführung einer
mathematischen methode in die
philosophie dieses michael damals
enthusiasmus vielleicht doch
gerechtfertigt betrachten wir frigges
prozedur genau unter den philosophischen
mikroskop ich möchte hier nur drei
probleme ausführen
ich habe noch mehr probleme
ausgearbeitet in einem kleinen buch über
schräge erstes problem
er stimmt eigentlich nicht dass frage
das subjekt und prädikat durch argument
um funktion ersetzt hat und obsolet
gemacht hat in der begriff schrift sind
alle urteile durch einen so genannten
urteil strich angezeigt
ganz rechts oben das sie wohl dafür
sowie das urteil archimedes stabe bei
vier akkus eines gewaltsamen todes zu
unterstrich in der gewaltsame tod des
archimedes passiert akkus ist eine
tatsache durch die schläge selbst sagt
ist das prädikat soll ist der ausdruck
ist eine tatsache weiterhin ein prädikat
wenn auch das einzige universal prädikat
designer begriff schließt mit anderen
worten die gewöhnliche subjekt prädikat
unterscheidung ist bloß die sich durch
eine neue kanonische form sublimiert
worden aber sie ist sozusagen immer noch
im hintergrund
außerdem ist der gewaltsame tod des
archimedes basina kloos eine
normalisierung der ursprünglichen
behauptung archimedes start bei vier
akkus eines gewaltsamen todes dass diese
finalisierung ist natürlich eine
bestimmte kennzeichnung eine description
nun können aber nicht alle bestimmten
kennzeichnungen zu subjekt der mini vom
prädikat ist eine tatsache werden
sondern nur ganz bestimmte nehmen sie
als gegenbeispiel den satz die
hauptstadt von bayern ist eine tatsache
dass sie so ansehen wollte ich hier eine
ich bestimmte kennzeichen kam und das
sind alle prädikat ist eine tatsache
welche bestimmten kennzeichnungen können
können sozusagen bedeutungsvoll mit ist
eine tatsache ergänzt werden eben
nominierungen von aussagen oder
behauptungen das heißt bestimmte
kennzeichnung denn die die ursprüngliche
grammatikalische form noch verraten
und das bedeutet die noch das
ursprüngliche wert enthalten die
vielgescholtene coppola zweites problem
schwenker behauptet dass begriffe das
wird ein bisschen komplizierter ich
bitte um entschuldigung aber das muss
man strenge behauptet dass begriffe
funktionen sind nun ergeben funktionen
die gesehen werte für argumente also
müssen auch begriffe werte für argumente
ergeben wie gesagt genauer der grieche
ergeben wahrheit' werte um ihre
argumente begriffe sind also funktionen
deren werte wahrheit' werte sind ein
beispiel nehmen wir als beispiel den
begriff 3 ist gleich zweimal y
für das argument y gleich 1,5 erhalten
sie natürlich dem wahrheit wird das war
wie sie ganz leicht nachrechnen können
sie das argument liebsten gleich fünf
erhalten wir dann wahrheit wird das
falsche um sofort nehmen wir nur ein nun
einen anderen bergischen begriff sex
schlecht
nehmen wir an dass sorg hat es
tatsächlich schläft während platon wach
ist
dann ist der wert von ex schlecht wie
das argument sokrates das war und wie
das argument platon das falsche nun ist
es aber eine kontingente tatsache dass
sokrates schläft er hätte genauso gut
wach sein können der satz hat es schläft
hat einen ordner und zucker des schläft
oder wach ist
tatsächlich hat dieser satz denselben
sehen denselben gedanken sowohl in einer
situation oder möglichen welt in der
sogar des schläft als auch in einer in
der er nicht schläft der sinn oder
gedanke von sokrates schläft diese
stabil über mögliche situationen hinweg
das erkennt man schon daran dass wir den
satz verstehen völlig unabhängig davon
ob wir schon wissen wie es um so hat es
steht also muss auch der wahrheit' wert
derselbe sein denn ein gedanke ist
nachfrage die gegebenheit weise des
wertes einer funktion für ein argument
ein gegenstand kann auf verschiedene
weise gegeben sein natürlich aber eine
gegeben
weise kann nicht zwei verschiedene
gegenstände präsentieren hätte der hätte
derselbe begriff ex schläft in einer
möglichen situation für das argument
sokrates einen wert nämlich das war und
in einer anderen möglichen situationen
oder contra faktischen situation wenn
sie wollen sie dasselbe argument einen
anderen wert nämlich das falsche dann
widerspreche das der sendung
fundamentale eigenschaft der funktionen
für ein argument genau einen wert um nur
diesen zu haben
wenn wir in zwei verschiedenen möglichen
situationen dieselbe funktion um
dasselbe argument haben das tun wir
dürfen wir auf gar keinen fall
verschiedene werte erhalten das aber ist
genau der fall bei kontingenten setzen
wie sokrates schläft und zum dritten
problem semantik erzählen uns heute viel
zeit habe ich noch ungefähr mannschaften
würde ich trotzdem machen die sind
detaillierte sein
ich bleibe beim zweiten meinen zweiten
problem denn gemäß kampf rege cancan
zweiges allgemeine charakterisierung von
begriffen als funktionen nicht richtig
sein denn sie kann ich mit einfachen
kontingenten setzen oder urteilen wie
sokrates schläft umgehen ein paralleler
ist sehr stark
erstaunliches problem wie bei leibnitz
beide kann ich mit kontinenten sätzen
umgehen und kontinente setzte sie nicht
marginale phänomene unserer sprache
sorry es sind die wichtigsten sätze
unsere sprache
da freuen uns aber von anfang an erzählt
hat dass er primär nur an der analyse
von mathematischen aussagen interessiert
ist sollte uns dieses ergebnis nicht
wundern strecke gibt eigentlich auch nie
ganz in seinem werk
beweis dafür dass begriffe funktionen
sind sondern er sagt nur er möchte das
wort begriff in analogie zum wort
funktion verwenden
und das ist auch sein gutes recht
dagegen kann man nichts sagen wenn uns
daher aber manche heutige semantik
erzählen dass das was sie setzte
ausdrücken ungesättigte bedeutung und
ratings wie zum beispiel eigenheim und
angelika kratzer in ihrem richtigen
hamburg semantics relativ grammer
erzählen wenn sie uns auch sein erzählen
noch mal das setzte die gesättigte
bedeutungen einhaltung einhalten also
begriffe als funktionen dann sollten wir
hier obacht walten lassen
dreht das problem dieselben semantik
erzählen uns auch dass freddys
funktionale analyse die grundlage der
formalen semantik bilden kann nicht alle
kinder einer grund- disziplin der
linguistik und sprachphilosophie denn
ich die tiere wieder heim und kratze
hier die frage wo sie steht in das
semantik komposition of seven seas und
weiter reinheim und kratzer ist
treatment of some and die komposition
voser funktional application zitat ende
mit anderen worten die funktionale
analyse schlicht uns zu verstehen wie
setzte und ihre bedeutungen
zusammengesetzt sind und wie wir sie
wieder zerlegen können ja wir können
scheinbar die bedeutungen schon setzen
sogar streng formal ableiten aus den
bedeutungen bestandteile der sätze nach
der funktionalen analyse sogar bei
setzen
bei komplizierteren setzen zum beispiel
bei international unter packen kontext
wie mary glaubt dass tom hinterließ neu
und das ist jetzt nicht so wichtig für
uns
haben wir hier also nicht endlich eine
streng mathematische methode der
zerlegen analyse und kalkulierbarkeit
zumindest in einem teilbereich der
philosophie gefunden
gern wir noch einmal zurück der wärter
funktion eco 2
für das argument 3 ist 9
man kann also die zahlen 9 verlegern als
den wert der funktion exakt 2 für das
argument 3 aber man kann die zahlen 9
aufzuerlegen als der wert der funktion
ex +91 für das argument - 82 oder als
den werther funktion ex minus 0,1 für
das argument 9,1
daraus folgt aber keineswegs dass die
zahl neun aus allen diesen zahlen
besteht komponiert ist sozusagen aus
unendlich vielen zahlen nämlich all den
argumenten ich glaube erwähnt habe - 82
391 und so fort die zahl 9 besteht nicht
aus und sie besteht auch nicht aus dem
funktion exakt zwei modernen funktionen
die ich erwähnt habe mit anderen worten
die funktionale analyse ergibt schon in
der mathematik überhaupt keine mario
logische oder und theologische zerlegung
in elementare bestandteile die
funktionale analyse erlaubt alternative
analysen eines gegebenen gegenstand
durch berechnung die ontologische
zerlegung soll dagegen die letzten
bestandteil eines gegenstands liefern
und lässt daher keine alternativen zu
das hat auch einen sehr wichtigen
gewohnt in pflege selbst diese tatsache
dass man mit das funktional diese
alternative analysen eines und dasselbe
der teilbaren inhalts oder gedanken
machen können weil er will natürlich
letztendlich seine logischen gegenstände
sozusagen logistisches projekte wie vor
allem
die extension von begriffen wie ich dir
dann beweist was soll das eigentlich was
zahlen sein sollen
diesen sachverhalt also nochmal die
ontologische zerlegung soll dagegen die
letzten bestandteil eines gegenstands
liefern und lässt daher keine
alternativen zu diesem sachverhalt
können wir direkt auf die funktionale
analyse von urteilen oder setzen
übertragen nachfrage steht der satz
wieder verfolgt fifi wieder gegenstand
das waren natürlich viele wie verfolgt
nach der funktionalen analyse kann
dieser gegenstand nun als der wahrheit'
werte der funktion ex erfolgt wie das
argument video angesehen werden
daraus folgt aber überhaupt nicht dass
der wahrheit wird das wahre aus dem fund
video und dem begriff ex verfolgt sie
zusammengesetzt ist der wahrheit wird
das war jetzt ein logischer häufiger
gegenstand sido ist leider ein
vergängliches lebewesen
denn der wahrheit wird das war können
wir auch als den werten der funktion
vieler verfolgt y oder gar als bewährte
funktion existiert für das argument
aristoteles funktional analysieren wir
haben also hier zum einen das problem
dass die funktionale analyse einen und
denselben satz in völlig verschiedene
gleichberechtigte argument funktion
strukturen auseinandernimmt und zum
anderen haben sie das problem das der
wahrheit wird das waren nicht
zusammengesetzt dies aus wieder fit
aristoteles und den unzähligen anderen
dingen über die
die ware urteile treffen können selbst
wenn wir frei geschenken dass es den
logischen gegenstand das wahre gibt und
das ist eine geschichte für sich ist es
schwer zu begreifen wie ein so
quicklebendiges ding wie unser dackel
wieder bestandteil eines solchen
logischen ewigen gegenstandes sein kann
das suggeriert dass freddys funktionale
analyse nicht die grundlage der
komposition semantisch sein kann auch
wenn es herrsche versuche von michael
dahme peter sullivan und anderen
vergebens regionen gegeben hat die
zerlege komposition eine analyse der
sätze mit dem funk mit der funktionalen
analyse zu versöhnen wenn also semantik
awi heim und kratze ihre formale
semantik auf funktionale analyse als
instrument semantischer zerlegung
einfach so ohne argument gründen als
würde es sich hier um eine
selbstverständliche wissenschaftliche
prozedur handeln wie bei der spaltung
des atoms sollten wir weiter skeptisch
bleiben
ich komme zum schluss ich habe die
möglichkeit fundamentale aspekte des
mathematischen paradies massiven
philosophieren von der karte leibnitz
und rege diskutiert und doch soll damit
nicht ausgeschlossen werden dass ist
auch andere das ist auf eine andere
weise in anderen bereichen
die philosophie von der mathematik
profitieren kann
was heute unter der rubrik mathematische
philosophie läuft liefert ja viele
beispiele
allerdings gibt es hier keinen
automatismus nehmen wir an wir haben es
mit einem philosophischen problem zu tun
sagen wir mit dem problem oder mit der
frage ob wissen eine form von
überzeugung ist diese neue form auflief
und uns präsentiert sich eine
mathematische struktur eines aspekt
dieses problems wir nehmen
beispielsweise an dass überzeugungen
frische funktionen sind denn das ist ja
überzeugenden ist ein begriff sein
wirklich schon seit des problems wir
nehmen jetzt einfach mal so an dass die
überzeugenden frische funktionen sind
und soweit ich mich nicht täusche habe
ich bin keine expertin der formalen ist
der mono geschieht das auf wir gewinnen
so einen bestimmten mathematischen
begriff einer überzeugung mit dem wir
dann viele interessante formale
resultate erzielen können
um aber sagen zu können dass dieser
resultate sache halt ich sind das heißt
wirklich das verhältnis zwischen dem
ursprünglichen begriff der überzeugung
und dem des wissens ausblick aufgeklärt
haben und wissen wir noch mindestens
zwei weitere dinge tun erstens abwägen
ob die aussage jede überzeugung ist eine
frische funktion buchstäblich war ist
und wenn ja dann wollen wir eine
rechtfertigung dafür haben uns war ein
apriori beweis glaube ich oder zweiten
sie müssen erwägen ob die aussage
nochmal die aussage jede überzeugung ist
eine frische funktion bloß eine analogie
formuliert nämlich ein nämlich tagung
eine analogie zwischen zwei grammatiken
oder sprachen oder darstellungs systemen
und wenn das der fall ist dann müssen
wir uns daran erinnern dass jeder
analogie irgendwo hinkt und aussagen
über das analogon nicht unbedingt nicht
automatisch auf den ursprünglichen rede
bereich übertragbar sind
wie soll die mathematisierung eines
philosophischen problems ist entscheidet
also der augenschein von fall zu fall
diese entscheidung also selbst keine
mathematische sein
daher sollten wir uns weiterhin an
platon halten denn ich anfangs erwähnte
über die höchsten prinzipien
menschlichen wissens auch des
mathematischen und mathematisierung
wissens kann doch nur die philosophische
reflexionen aufklären oder wir sollten
auch auf kans warnung hören nämlich der
warnung vor der methoden sucht
habe es verpasst
ok also sie sollte noch mal auf ganz auf
ganz warnung hören vor der methoden
sucht in der nachahmung des
mathematikers die auf dem schlüpfrigen
wurden der metaphysik eine menge feld
wieder veranlasst hat wer aber platon
und kant für alte hüther hält und nur
auf zeitgenössischer logik gehört der
sein soll kriegs diktum erinnert der
islam ein fanartikel philosophie danke